nuevas pistas surgen desde la cárcel de
santo domingo de tsáchilas en el oeste
de ecuador después de que unos
enfrentamientos acabarán con la vida de
más de una decena de personas las
autoridades anunciaron que encontraron
múltiples armas blancas y de fuego en el
interior del recinto un fusil automático
de asalto y una pistola resaltan de los
nuevos hallazgos que se suman a la
hipótesis de que la matanza se produjo
debido a una rivalidad entre bandas se
comprende que una fracción de los
denominados seres 7 que era un apéndice
de los chones killers que tomaron el
control del centro penitenciario
fueron
alertados supuestamente de la creación
de otra organización un grupo de
delincuencia organizada liderado por
alias goyo que es uno de los que perdió
la vida en este amotinamiento
mientras las autoridades avanzan en las
investigaciones la conmoción rodea a los
familiares de las víctimas a las afueras
de la cárcel demandan verdad y justicia
además de nuevas garantías hace tan sólo
dos meses más de 40 reclusos murieron en
la misma prisión
y
más de 400 personas han muerto en las
prisiones del país desde 2020 y solo en
2022 ya son cerca de 80 los fallecidos
la comisión interamericana de derechos
humanos recomendó al estado ecuatoriano
retomar el control interno de las
prisiones dar condiciones dignas a los
presos y modificar la política del
delito hacia una donde no prime el
encarcelamiento